Joe Biden carefully picked the time and
place for his first major address of the
2024 campaign
today I make this sacred pledge to you
the defense protection and preservation
of American democracy will remain as it
has been the central cause of my
presidency the time a day before the
three-year anniversary of the
Insurrection in Washington his presumed
rival is charged with leading that
effort to forcibly overturn the results
of the 2020 presidential election Trump
exhausted every legal Avenue available
to him to overturn the election
everyone but the legal path just took
Trump back to the
truth that I had won the election and he
was a
loser the place near Valley Forge where
George Washington's troops set up camp
in the Cradle of American democracy and
not coincidentally in Pennsylvania a key
swing state it's a state Pennsylvania
Senator John fedman says Biden can and
must win talk about really what the
election is on the line too uh democracy
or a dictator somebody that actually
comes right on really proclaimed it's
like I'm going to be a dictator um and
some people might not take him seriously
but but I certainly would take it
seriously Biden won the state in 2020 by
a single percentage point it was near
here at Valley Forge that in 1777 George
Washington set up camp the US had
declared its independence but still had
to fight for this budding democracy that
is what Joe Biden says needs to happen
now the US needs to fight for
democracy today we're here to answer the
most important of questions is democracy
still America's sacred
cause need it as Biden launched his
political campaign near Philadelphia
Trump continued his campaign in Iowa the
first state to vote in a Republican
primary less than two weeks away he's
saying I'm a threat to democracy he's a
threat to De democracy W
okay couldn't read the word he's a
threat to democracy you know how bad the
Press is you know what they do they take
me saying that like that and they say
Trump couldn't say the word democracy
both the president and the former
president will have to first win their
party's nominations state by state John
hendin Al jazer Montgomery County
Pennsylvania make sure to subscribe to
our channel to get the latest news from
Al
jazer